- [Voiceover] Let's say
that we have a particle
that's traveling in one
dimension, and its position
as a function of time is given as t
to the third power plus
two over t-squared.
What I would like you to
do is pause this video
and figure out what the
average acceleration is
of this particle over the
interval, the closed interval,
from t is equal to one
to t is equal to two.
What is this?
What is this going to be equal to?
Assuming you've given a
go, and the first thing you
might have realized is we're
trying to get the average
value of a function that we
don't know explicitly at.
We know the position function
but not the acceleration function.
But luckily, we also know
that the acceleration function
is derivative with respective
time of the velocity function
which is the derivative with respect
to time of the position function.
The acceleration function is
the second derivative of this.
We have to just find its average
value over this interval.
Let's do that.
Let's take the derivative of this twice.
But before we do that, let
me just even rewrite this.
It's just going to be a little bit
easier to differentiate it.
If we just take each of these
two terms in the numerator
and divide them by t
squared, we're going to get t
to the third, divided by
t-squared is just the t.
Then two divided by T
squared, we could write that
as plus two t to the negative two power.
Now, let's take the derivative.
The velocity function, as
the velocity as the function
of time, just the derivative
with this with respect to time.
It's going to be derivative
of t with respect to t as one.
Derivative of two t to the negative two.
Let's see, negative two times
positive two is negative four.
T to the, we just decremented
the exponent here,
t to the negative three power.
Now, to find acceleration as
a function of time, we just
find, take the derivative of
this with respect to time.
Acceleration as a function
of time is equal to,
actually it's already used
at color for the average
so let me do a different color now.
Acceleration has a
function of time is just
the derivative of this with respect to t.
Derivative of a constant with respect
to time was not changing so it's a zero.
Then over here, negative three times
negative four is positive
12, times t to the,
let's decrement that exponent
to the negative four power.
Now to find the average
value, all we have to do now,
average value is essentially
take the definitive role
of this over the interval, and divide that
by the width of the interval.
Or we could say, we could take,
we can divide by the
width of the interval.
One, over two minus one,
and this also simplifies to one.
Times the definitive role of the interval.
One to two of a of t which is,
so this could be 12 t to
the negative four power d t.
What is this simplified to?
Once again, this is one over one.
That's just going to be one.
We take the antiderivative of this.
Let me just, so this
is going to be equal to
the antiderivative of this
is, so we go t to the negative
three power but we
divide by negative three.
An antiderivative of this
is going to be, if we don't
take that, an antiderivative
is going to be negative four
t to the negative three power,
and we saw that over here.
Obviously, if you were really
just taking an in-definitive
role, we would have to
put some concept here.
But in the definitive role,
if we put a concept here,
Assuming the same concept
that we get canceled out
when you actually do a
calculation, but the entire
derivative of this, we
increment the exponent,
and then we divide by that new exponent.
Twelve divided by negative
three is negative four.
We are going to evaluate
that from two and that one.
This is going to be equal to,
when we evaluated it at two
at the upper bound of our
intervals, it could be
negative four times two to
the negative three powers.
It's negative four times, what is that?
Two, that's one over to
the third of times 1/8,
is one way to think about that.
Then we are going to have
minus this evaluated one.
Minus negative four times
t to the negative three
of one to the negative three is just one.
This is going to be
negative four times one.
This is going to be equal to,
or really in the homestretch now,
this is equal to, this part right
over here, is negative 1/2.
This is negative 1/2, and this part
right over here is positive four.
Positive four minus 1/2.
We could either write
that as three and a half,
or if we wanted to write
that as an improper fraction,
we could write this as 7/2.
The average value of our acceleration
over this interval is 7/2.
If this position was given a
meters and time was in seconds,
then this would be 7/2
meters per seconds squared,
is the average acceleration between time
in one second and time at two seconds.